just as President Trump is pushing for a
massive increase in the Pentagon's
budget a new audit says the Defense
Department has lost hundreds of millions
of dollars national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin has the
latest tonight from the Pentagon the
Pentagon can't account for 800 million
dollars that according to a shocking
internal audit of the Defense Logistics
Agency done by Ernst & Young the
Department of Defense continues to have
unresolved accounting issues and is
unable to provide sufficient evidential
support for complete and accurate
financial statements on a timely basis
raising questions about how the Pentagon
is managing taxpayer money the White
House plans to ask for billions more for
defense on top of its current 700
billion dollar budget the largest in the
federal bureaucracy
last year the Pentagon comptroller
ordered an audit for the first time ever
it's been clear to me for 25 years they
never followed the money everybody
respects the military and we ought to
they put their lives on the line for our
freedom and liberties we ought to but I
think they get too much leeway just
because of that respect Ernst & Young
found that the Defense Logistics Agency
which oversees Pentagon purchasing and
has been compared to Walmart failed to
document eight hundred million dollars
in construction projects DLA employs 25
thousand people and processes 100,000
orders a day a spokesperson for the
agency responded quote DLA concurs with
Ernst & Young's assessment of our
failure to properly account for and
track funding to specific construction
projects while there were shortcomings
in documentation there was no loss of
accountability of real property or
associated funding some experts are
willing to give DLA the benefit of the
doubt if you look back at some of the IT
systems that DoD uses for its accounting
and financial systems some of them date
back to you know the 1960s 1970s the
past 10 years defense secretary after
defense secretary has tried to begin a
complete audit of the Pentagon by law
they were supposed to complete one by
December 3rd
first now we are learning the cost of
such an audit could top more than a
billion dollars Brett Jumoke tell us
about US troop drawdown in Iraq
well Pentagon officials tell us hundreds
of US troops have started to leave Iraq
but about seven thousand US troops
remain on the ground there to Train
local forces most of American troops
will return to the US but some are
headed to Afghanistan among them drone
units that provide badly needed
intelligence and surveillance Iran has
long pressured Iraq to rid itself of US
troops this announcement follows Iraq's
declaration in December that the fight
against Isis is over and precedes an
election in Iraq in May Brett Jennifer
Griffin live at the Pentagon Jennifer
thank you